i wanted to
put up another video today because
i want to do this before too much time
elapses since i left levive
and it's a video that i did with
constantine
who lives in cave
and who has a very interesting program
where he mobilizes people in a community
to help language learners
use link and understand link and get
more out of their language learning
experience
uh la viv is a city of many cultures
many churches
many languages
much music it's a delightful place to
visit very good food i might add so it's
appropriate then in this setting to give
you a bit of a flavor of lev where i
spent five days and here the perspective
of constantine with his unique
uh program of language coaching
for russian speakers which he
runs out of his
main place of work which is in kiev
ukraine
and without further ado here is that
video interview bye for now
here we are in la viv with constantine
hello
my friend constantine who lives in
who's here on business and i'm here and
we're both sort of
language nomads in a way
and we are in the courtyard this is the
back of the armenian church here
and i was here two years ago with my
wife
and uh there was a string quartet
playing right here and they have free
music levi is a city of music
they have some of the best street music
performers
and certainly listening to a string
quartet in this lovely uh old church
courtyard was a marvelous experience
and
it has also been shoot and shot in many
movies like soviet oh really yeah like i
guess even three musketeers really they
want to hear some of the scenes
definitely
you know we were commenting on how
obviously travel brings people closer
together language can bring people
closer together
now there's so many more opportunities
to to find language resources
like i mentioned in twitter that i
i was at the the book fair in
cave the uh
and i had while learning ukrainian
always been looking for audiobooks in
ukrainian could never find any i mean
very few and now there's a company that
puts them out so things are always
developing
and so and and lo and behold i can i get
their app for my iphone
and it says most popular audiobook in
ukraine i download the most popular
audiobook and then i'm with my ukrainian
teacher and she finds somewhere the
ebook and i import it and now i have
this to study on me i mean it's you're
very lucky and i'm carrying in my
iphone that we're now using to film this
but
i mean uh
like a library of content from simple
stories to audio books
you name it
richer than any language lab
any it used to be you go to a language
lab because that's the only place you
would find listening resources you would
hardly find such ukrainian about exactly
well certainly not for ukrainian but
even for other languages
just some background
uh constantine lives in kiev
and he has developed a program
where he deals with
essentially the russian-speaking world
yeah
any russian speaker any russian speakers
and this is the other thing about the
world today russian speaker doesn't just
mean moscow or saint petersburg it could
be habarovsk
it could mean yeah it even goes beyond
that and it goes beyond four mercy's
countries right so it might be any
russian speaker in europe
latin america new zealand states new
zealand
yeah definitely had a wonderful student
from new zealand and and
constantine uses link with his learners
but what he does is i think very
valuable in that he has a whole system
for providing more support
because i think a lot of people are
easily discouraged or they don't fully
understand link
or they lose interest and i think all of
us can benefit from a little bit of
support and guidance as as is the case
with my tutor here solomia sure i'm
going to do a video with tomorrow
morning but
so you have this world now where people
are connecting through language
connecting with people like you like me
like solomia who are helping people
learn languages and it's become easier
absolutely um there are so many people
that i'm somehow i found myself get
connected to
thanks to the language learning even
though i for example i don't speak
german but uh there's a german learner
russian speaker ryan kazakhstan i feel
kind of so fellow in kazakhstan a
russian speaker living in kazakhstan
he's learning german learning german and
i actually i'm guiding him through the
process of learning german even though i
don't speak it right
yeah exactly and uh then we shared
we sheriff dos
he shares materials with me that i might
consider when i i finally come to german
learning right so it's just incredible
and uh it really brings people together
and creates those bonds
between people
and and hopefully we are able to
persuade people that anyone can learn
anyone can learn um to
to different degree of proficiency
absolutely so there is a i would say
that there is a talent like there is a
talent for playing music playing the
piano some people do it just better
and the more you do it the better you
get that's absolutely yeah but um
does it really matter that some people
learn better than others because if you
say that the starting point isn't zero
ability in language x
you put in
y amount of time sure you will achieve
something yeah and maybe learner
b will learn faster than learner a but
that doesn't take
pleasure away from learner hey sure for
his achieve or her achievements yeah
well people are so you should see
people's faces uh when they um
you know
in their lifetime they could hardly
imagine themselves speaking english for
instance right or any other language and
then they
for example i've had a class recently
with
my student uh i think we we started
having classes
two years ago
and then he went to amsterdam and he had
just he had a vacation with his wife
around amsterdam this was his first time
and he was so happy because he was
screaming to me like i could understand
everything they said everything every
single word and they understood the name
right so he could actually manage
to reply
and there was a funny case he said that
they stopped by a certain cafe or a
coffee shop right and he asked for a
menu and he was looking through that for
15 minutes trying to figure out what was
written and i kind of was struggling
with that and his wife started arguing
and scolding him
she said like you have invested two
years of your life into language
learning like english language learning
but you're not even able to read the
menu
and then he figured out he was actually
reading a menu in dutch
uh yeah but still he could
you know find his way through it however
i find menus difficult
absolutely not easy like i i manage in
my ukrainian i can read the history of
ukraine if i given get given a menu in
ukrainian i got lots of trouble i i'd
like to look at and then i ask for the
english menu so that i can figure out
what i'm going to order but you see
venues are not easy life was not aware
right
yeah but still um and this is the
moments that bring
real inspiration they keep you going
that you understand that you contributed
something to the person's life
it's amazing
well on that positive note we are and
we're not
i guess we enjoy helping other people
learn languages absolutely that gives us
enjoyment it makes sense it's a good
thing to do all right and now we're
going to grab some dinner sure
bye for now take care
you